right back I love modeling famous
entrepreneurs I love looking up a
successful entrepreneur seeing what made
them achieve their success and copying
their strategy and put it to work for me
and one of my favorite stories is of
Leon Leon would beam he's the founder of
LL Bean and one of the things that he
did consistently is right back the
people now in his day and age there
wasn't Twitter and Facebook and YouTube
and all that but people wrote him
letters and I remember seeing this
picture of him on his desk with a sock
full of letters and he was their
handwriting responses back to the people
who wrote in to him and he could have
given that to somebody else to do but he
felt like it was one of the most
important roles in the business to write
back to customers who wrote in and so he
did it himself he didn't he had to stay
late and he wrote back to everybody and
I think that's a great policy for for
you guys to adopt for me to adopt and I
try to live that and it's not just know
we don't write that many letters anymore
right but you get emails you get tweets
you got facebook responses you get
YouTube comments I try to write back to
everybody I don't always hit everybody
but i have like I'm like a ninety-nine
percent hit right where if you're
writing to me if you're tweeting to me
if you're commenting I right back to you
and what it does is it makes people feel
recognized makes people feel important I
don't know how many YouTube channels
I've looked at and commented on and I've
never heard back from that person again
what if that person is fro back to me
and said hey Evan thanks to a comment or
looked me a little smiley face or
something you know that that would make
me want to come back more often and so
do that you know if somebody writes into
you it should be really important that
you get back to them and it's not just
emails across all your social channels
if somebody calls you should call them
back right one of my favorite quotes
from from llbean was a customer is the
most important person ever in this
office in person or by mail and when he
died over 50,000 people wrote in to the
company to express her condolence
fifty thousand people because they cared
they loved him because he loved them and
he responded he wrote back so right back
everybody who connects with you and
believe those are you watching I love to
hear what you have to think tell me if
you are going to start writing back tell
me how you're writing back now leave a
comment underneath you like this video
give it a thumbs up and click on my face
face there subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon